good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy hump day it is Wednesday
hope everyone has exerted some energy
got their morning workout in humping the
one that they love whether that is human
whether that is animal we do not judge
here at the morning toast hey Jax
one question for you how you're done I'm
doing good thanks for asking so exciting
that it's hump day I do hope everyone is
humping someone they love
now later whatever suits you I think
that's absolutely beautiful I love
starting off the show with that kind of
peaceful harmonious energy before we
start attacking one another
I don't ever want to attack you no me
neither
um maybe we could lay down our weapons
for one day you know we'll see where the
show takes us I feel like if there's any
day for us to pick up our weapons it's a
hump day you think so
it brings out that energy that feral
energy in in others I guess you never
know what could happen the stories I
don't think the stories like will land
on different sides of anything but since
when do we only talk about the stories
so true we've got to talk about
ourselves and today is a huge day for us
you know we were being annoying a few
weeks ago on set being models months ago
this was July oh okay so months ago we
were like being annoying secret project
girlies and because we're the type of
influencers and celebrities who are
going to tell you what secret project
correlates to which annoying time we
just launched on our Instagram Jackie
and I are one of the many faces of the
new PJ place which is the Children's
Place company they launched their own
pajama line the pajamas are fabulous
fabulous and I wear them every single
day since July they are so amazing and
you know they just hired a couple of
models us Khloe Kardashian Kris Jenner
Tyler Cameron Kevin Hart
um so just some of our fellow models in
the campaign and you can check it out on
our Instagram stories and posts and it's
just like life of a model you know
another day another sleigh another day
another campaign another day another
shoot
being a model is like people like look
at our lives and they see two models and
they're probably like wow that must be
amazing they don't realize how hard it
is to be a model no it's really hard to
be a model like I'm actually not kidding
anymore and if that actually is that
we're my full-time job I would not
thrive in the position no after the
photo shoot me and Jackie like we I was
not okay like I was so tired photo
shoots are so hard like you have to
stand straight for like 12 hours
straight like it's really nice you just
have to like move one muscle this yeah
and you also like have to be confident
and be feeling yourself it's just a lot
even if you're not it's still mental and
physical I know it sounds like crazy
like modeling is hard
um but it was not what you would expect
no and that you know doesn't go to say
that it's any more difficult than being
a coal miner of course but it's just not
as easy as it looks honestly like photo
shoots are not my jam like for the first
like 20 minutes I'm always having so
much fun I'm like yes I'm literally
Kendall Jenner and then like I see the
pictures of myself I'm like oh I'm I'm
not Kendall Jenner you're kidding I
think it's also probably hard that
people
probably think oh modeling so easy how
hard is it to be a model whereas like
coal mining is hard but everyone
respects coal miners that's true
actually that's such a true statement so
I'm sure that helps the coal miners and
get through it get through those rough
times 100
um so we're looking sickening if you
want to go look at our um and we're like
not wearing any makeup like we literally
woke up they asked for a natural look
and so we're natural girlies like we're
naturally beautiful that's kind of my
personal takeaway from the whole
experience and PJ plays is just like
making you feel naturally beautiful and
the pajamas are sickening like I'm truly
like I'm very very
um particular you know me skeletons are
bust and these pass my tests and this is
not even a sponsored episode I was just
really Blown Away by the pajamas yeah
and the premium content that we just
posted that you should go check out and
now you can shop at PJ place
so other than that we have a Fab show
we've got Fast Five it's wetness day
which means we have deer toasters which
I'm super excited about just to save
some lives you know it's always good
when you can wake up and save a life
Trails I imagine That's How The Fray
felt I met someone in Atlanta who had
written into Deer toasters and hers was
the one about the girl who was like
flirting with her husband and we the
advice we gave was assess the threat yes
and so she showed me a picture was the
threat accessible the threat was
assessed this girl has nothing to worry
about mostly because she's so fabulous
not to put down another woman but it's
just like I met this girl and I was like
you are a Godless entity you don't need
to be threatened by others and the girl
will be invited to her wedding because
she assessed that the threat had been
neutralized you absolutely love to see
women supporting other threats
you do women helping other women
neutralize threats
debt and I detonate
the threats that's so good that's a fun
word to say threat
um
so we'll do that into your toasters just
like change save and
heal impact
another girl yeah that's a good word
another good word we're all about the
words today yeah like short Punchy words
and we're short Punchy girls ain't that
the truth so we've got a Fab show
there's no TV recap so we can really
dive into the deer toasters dive into
the stories
um tomorrow actually right after this
I'm I was that girl like walking through
the street today with my suitcase which
is probably my least favorite girl to be
um I don't think there's anything and
for no reason there's nothing more
embarrassing than being a grown woman
walking through the streets with a
suitcase like suitcases are meant for
the airport and that's pretty much it
but I am headed to Nashville tonight for
my show tomorrow so tomorrow's episode
I'm gonna do from our hotel room it'll
still be up and I decided to go a night
early so I could see Shannon Ford so I
could have dinner with her I feel like I
just saw Shannon because I was listening
to her podcast episode with James her
man's yeah with her man's and they're so
sweet I'm sure everybody has been
following their American getaway where
they just like took the country by storm
no it made me wanna I wanna move to
America and I I felt like I didn't live
there I want to come back in my next
life as like Shannon Ford's
International boyfriend who gets to
experience America Through The Eyes of
Shannon Ford you know what I don't even
I won't be greedy like I want to come
back in my next life is like Shannon
Ford's handbag like I just want to be
near Shannon Ford you know yeah well you
could be really near to her if you
listen to her podcast probably a podcast
she puts out premium
her videos are so sickening and this
week was no different it was so cute to
hear just like hear them be in a
relationship you know yeah it was really
cute really cute so
um
yeah I really don't have much else oh I
will like while I'm like worshiping the
ground she walks on I'll be sure to be
like oh Jackie wishes she was here yeah
also do your show is tomorrow Thursday
okay so like don't get too crazy I know
you could get carried away with Shannon
no I can get carried away with Shannon
but like one thing about me that I think
a lot of people don't like expect
because I'm like a party animal I Can't
Be Tamed when it comes to my shows like
I respect Wellness like I do not drink
before shows I don't drink the day of
show I won't drink like within 48 Hours
of my show after a show all bets are off
unless I have a show the next day but I
really respect like my work ethic does
not include drinking I do not do that
nice I was like the one time I
restrained myself I was randomly
thinking about how I feel like since we
started doing these episodes since I
moved like you really haven't been
hungover for one of them yeah well I
have like an internal battle with the
hangover episodes because they age
really well well like people love them
but when I'm doing them like I feel like
you know my the main part of my job is
to wake up and deliver a kick-ass show
yeah and if I don't do that it feels
like my whole day is a waste so when I'm
doing The Hangover episodes maybe I'm
like shame spiraling but I feel really
bad when I do them I feel like I don't
get a good job done you have to carry
the show so I feel like there was a
period maybe a year ago where I was
doing it kind of frequently and part of
me was like
doing the episode getting drunk so that
I could do drunk episodes because people
love them but I don't know I just felt
like I wasn't doing a good job at my job
do you know what I mean I I fully
understand what you're saying but also
some people love them it's just like the
singing like some people love them like
literally favorite episodes other people
couldn't tolerate yeah now when I go
back and like see Clips I love it but in
the moment like I know I was not feeling
proud I understand that and so just like
everything else if people are gonna like
it or dislike it you should just decide
what you like yeah so like don't get me
wrong if somebody invites me to a Fab
event on a Thursday like I'm going balls
to the wall and I'll show up here
hungover maybe it's just that I haven't
been invited to a Fab event maybe it's
that also I was thinking about how
painful it would be to do an episode in
these headphones with a hangover oh my
God you would have to swap to buds yeah
no these um headphones hit different
yeah they're squeezing the [ __ ] out of
my ears I know I want to get a pair of
different headphones I think I always am
talking about this but I haven't found
what I want which is just like over the
ear headphones bones that look nice that
are loose but I also want you guys to be
able to see my hair no sometimes the
headphones hide a bad hair day
purple which is the brand that makes my
favorite smelly pillow needs to come out
with a pair of headphones
yeah Beats by purple that have like the
gel Flex insert gel Flex that's a good
collab idea yeah free idea that one gets
the gbt stamp of approval
also our Rebrand got the gbt oh talk
about that if you guys remember
um during Jackie's maternity leave if
you know her from Tick Tock like you
know but if you're not a tick tock or a
girl boss Town who's kind of become like
the Gen Z branding and marketing expert
she did a video on our Rebrand and gave
it her stamp of approval she said she
loved the the aesthetic she loved the
partnership with deer media she thought
it was genius on all fronts people in
the comments were also like this is just
a genie like everyone was like
complimenting us it was such a nice
change such a nice change
I loved it um but we've got a Fab show
I'm ready to dive in we do I'm ready to
dive in there's just one more thing that
I wanted to talk about if I know because
serious voice alert serious voice no
because yesterday we didn't talk much
about the Kanye situation because we
just like weren't in the mood and I also
like didn't have the words yet for what
I was feeling to talk about them on the
show like I never want to come on here
with like a half-baked thought agreed
and I also think like we should
normalize like processing things and not
just 100 normalized taking the time and
and not just like regurgitating what
everyone else is saying because it feels
like you have to say something when
you're not sure what you want to say yet
and so I know what I want to say and so
I just want to talk about it for a
second I don't want to like make oh it's
not a story it's not a story I don't
want to make anti-Semitism a story like
the story you know what the stories are
like that and if we ever want to talk
about serious topics which we do
sometimes we always do it at the front
of the episode you know okay
um so I love that by the way let's not
make anti-Semitism a story and I also
think like normal realize thinking
before you speak so I totally
agree I was like so fatigued by it and I
was just like annoyed and upset by it so
the idea of like doing it at work I was
just not in the mood for but when you
called me today and you were like let's
talk about it I'm ready I was like you
know what okay fine
um and I feel like
for a little backstory for anyone who
might not know like what went down I'm
sure you do Kanye was on one of his many
rants on Instagram over the weekend and
there was like a few it's funny because
everyone is obviously talking about the
Defcon 3 text he sent to who was it he
tweeted that oh
um everyone was talking about that but
for me I was like watching his whole
Saga go down like that whole week he was
posting a lot on Instagram he did a big
interview and there was like a few
things that he said that like triggered
something in my brain like if you're
Jewish you're like very um
like even very you're sensitive and very
like subtle things you're like what was
that a little yeah and then when he did
the Defcon 3 tweet it just kind of
yeah wrapped the whole thing up in a bow
right and I think the beginning things
where people were like oh this is subtly
anti-semitic
um like the Kushner thing you didn't get
much traction outside of like the Jewish
Community because we were all had our
antennas on we're like yeah so I
couldn't figure out like exactly what
about the situation is bothering me
obviously Kanye's tweet is diabolical I
don't know what Defcon 3 on Jewish
people means um I don't know that I want
to know I'm a little scared so totally
and like prior what was that no go ahead
no and prior to that like the things he
had been saying in his text messages
that he screenshotted were just like
very
um like harking back to some of the
worst tropes about Jews like that we
control the media and the money yeah and
everything like that is a very very
common thing that like I feel like is
such an Antiquated stereotype but it's
so prevalent like the amount of people
who thought that like Jews invented the
vaccine like it's still so prevalent
like and it's really damn Jing because
it leads to
terrible terrible things right so people
started paid attention to the
anti-Semitism once he said death country
on Jews he was like d platform from
Twitter he was de-platformed already
from Instagram for saying that like
Diddy's business people were Jewish and
right he wasn't able to post after that
because of that and now everyone or a
lot of people more than usual are being
like Kanye's anti-Semitism like to
switch more than usual way more than
usual and
while I guess I'm glad that
anti-Semitism is getting a spotlight
here's what it is like I don't want to
be ungrateful because people are finally
finally acknowledging anti-Semitism even
though on the scale of like anti-semitic
things that have happened in the last
year this is very uh like local yeah
it's low grade so I don't want to be
ungrateful but like I am suspicious I
know that sounds crazy yeah I'm I am
suspicious and now that I've like had
time to think about it this is where
I've landed with it so Kanye had a very
hectic week last week
and business he had his Yeezy fashion
show where he wore a shirt that said
White lives matter and this started
everyone in hysterics over this shirt
but people what can people really do
about him wearing that shirt what are
they going to say that he's racist he's
a bad man like right he's calling out
that BLM was a scam and he's wearing a
shirt that says white lives matter and
like this really enraged people he
continued all week to talk like posting
on Instagram he did a big interview you
know he's very pro-life people don't
like that about him and but you really
can't people couldn't at that time like
take him down for something like that
right right so now he says this thing
Defcon 3 to the Jews and he's given
everyone the reason to cancel him
because what he said is [ __ ] crazy
right and it feels like everyone who's
so eager to cancel him about this
doesn't care about actual anti-Semitism
aside from the Jewish people who are
posting about it the Jewish activist and
Megan McCain
always always supporting the juice yeah
so it just felt so performative to me
especially because the more I watch some
of the things that he said there was
like more leaked clips from his
interview with Tucker Carlson the more a
lot of what he's saying he is
um
regurgitating talking points from like
Louis Farrakhan who is a big Pastor he's
a pastor and he um and no sorry before
he's a pastor he's an anti-semite big
time anti-semite if you don't know about
his anti-Semitism you could look it up
you know he said that Hitler was a great
man he called Jews termites he's also a
major homophobe he said horrible things
about the LGBT community
demonic [ __ ] wild a lot of people in
Hollywood subscribe him subscribe to him
we've talked about him before like with
Nick Cannon I think a lot but Nick
Cannon said on his show that resulted in
a temporary cancellation was direct
talking points from Louis Farrakhan but
a lot of other celebrities either
sometimes say these things or also are
followers of his yeah they like go to
his sermons it's such a weird [ __ ]
play it's such a weird Flex there are so
many celebrities who do and and they're
not canceled even the ones who have said
the same things that Louis Farrakhan has
said have not been canceled for what
they've said right
Kanye saying these same things when this
has been going on in Hollywood for a
very long time and none of those people
are canceled right no it just it goes
without saying that like this is being
blown up because it's Kanye and he has
become this like polarizing figure in
the last year so for someone who
actually cares about anti-Semitism I
don't feel the genuine love and like
want for change from social media and
celebrities and influencers who are
posting about it it feels 100
performative and I hate to like I hate
to complain because like for the first
time like we're getting support but I
don't think it's coming from a genuine
place because I I think what we've
learned over the last couple of years
like really nobody cares about like
you're telling me like all this uproar
for Kanye who like nobody really takes
seriously like all this uproar for Kanye
when like
less than a year ago like people in New
York City in La were literally getting
beat up on the street for being Jewish
temples were being uh defaced nobody
said a word they still are every single
day there is at least one but usually
multiple instances of anti-Semitism in
this country violence like anti-Semitism
in real life not just Social Media stuff
online like we talked about it in New
York City there's this tablet magazine
article that it's open season on Jews in
New York City hundreds of anti-Semitic
attacks against Jews and only one person
has even served one day in jail
people don't care and now with Kanye's
Tweet now AOC gets to come out against
anti-Semitism when in her state in her
City the cases of actual anti-semitic
violence are so [ __ ] high but no one
is doing anything about it so that's
what bothers me
yeah and I just feel like to your point
there's so many instances of like way
worse and I hate to like diminish
because I just I can't blanket statement
like can't say enough like how what
Kanye said was wrong yeah and this is
not the first time he said something
anti-semitic like in 2013 he blamed his
low concert sales ticket sales on the
Jews like this is not the first time
like this is a problem this is a problem
um but I I would love for people to
bring this energy to other other
celebrities I mean I like let's let's
talk about let's mention it all Bella
Hadid like Bella Hadid is not a beloved
member from the Jewish Community like we
do not feel safe around her she went on
a podcast like two months ago basically
talking about how like all of the Jewish
people in her life like don't really
talk to her anymore they won't invite
her over to their house like oh I wonder
why
and so she's like out here being a
victim like my Jewish friends well why
aren't they talking to you and like Diet
prod is posting this podcast being like
she's so brave she's Brave uh if like
all the people in your life from a
certain Community aren't talking to you
anymore like maybe you're the problem
yeah no but her face just go everywhere
you can't go anywhere without where's
the energy let's keep up the energy
everyone let's keep it up and it's like
Bella is supposed to remember when she
posted a picture of her friends and then
her friend was literally arrested the
next day for beating the [ __ ] up a Jew
in the street I know him I went to Camp
with him committing a hate crime against
Jews and she stayed up right and she
never said anything like
no so here I love the energy we've
brought for Kanye let's amp it up with
everyone else and everything else and
all the other anti-Semitism all the what
are what is it 92 of hate crimes against
Jewish people when we account for two
percent of the population let's keep up
that energy I love it yes yeah keep it
up
and until we do this I'm suspicious
Rings performative phony and convenient
performative that's the word that is the
word
so those are my thoughts
obviously I hope you enjoyed that
incredibly disappointed like I don't
know how to enjoy Kanye again no he's
you know what I'm not even disappointed
because he was really [ __ ] annoying
me the last couple of months so like now
I'm like bi annoying
um and that's also part of the reason I
didn't want to talk about it because
like I don't I don't like I'm so over
him like he's out of my like off my list
okay yeah
yeah but like and this is and this
conversation does not stem from like
being obsessed with the Kardashians like
because I've been over Kanye for a
really long time yeah no but also I
don't think the Kardashians are obsessed
with Kanye right he causes them a lot of
trouble a lot of grief so he needs to
stop like now and so does everyone yeah
no actually everyone needs to keep going
keep going we want all of this energy
please always and bring it to the Jews
of Brooklyn who literally can't walk
down the street in religious Garb
without getting beat up oh and their
assailants even when caught don't face
any serve any time
totally totally totally let's keep up
the energy I'm gonna be counting on all
of you all you who are posting I'm
counting on you I'll be checking in
so those are my thoughts
my blood pressure's up should we should
we dive in yeah let's take it down a
notch with the last five stories that
you need to know before sorry I [ __ ]
up the first time stories that you need
to know period wait do it again here are
the satisfied stories that you need to
know period
gorgeous absolutely gorgeous oh I'm
sorry and just one more thing about the
whole Kanye thing the worst part about
all of this and this anti-semitic Trope
is that when someone does get canceled
for saying what they say about the Jews
you know the Jews
yeah then that becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy because you just espouse
anti-Semitism so yes you are going to
get backlash and that only makes that
person more anti-semitic more firm in
their beliefs that the Jews control
everything and we don't get anywhere
better so I do love when someone like
Nick Cannon like sits down with a rabbi
yeah I don't know who Kanye would listen
to I don't think any of the Jews that he
knows are the ones to do it no no I I
agree like with the Nick Cannon thing I
felt like that's I think it needs to be
us
oh 100 I welcome the idea
um also like I feel like the Nick Cannon
case study of anti-Semitism like I think
like first of all the way he handled it
was great I think the way we handled it
was great as a community like I don't
think we came at it with anger we came
at it with like genuine wanting to
assist and I think that's always going
to be more helpful and I actually think
like he learned something so I think
everyone should take a look at Nick
Cannon I also don't get the sense that
Kanye has any idea about Jewish history
about religious about Jews in America
outside of Hollywood I don't think he
knows anything I do think he could be
educated I don't think he'll apologize
he doesn't apologize I don't think he's
sorry I don't think he didn't mean what
he said but I just I don't really feel
like that's a fair excuse like you're a
40 year old man no no no I'm sorry I'm
not saying that it's an excuse I'm
saying that as an opportunity like yeah
no I know but learn about that Holocaust
I think that would be helpful
as a human being to learn about the
Holocaust maybe you didn't learn about
it growing up but you live in LA you're
I don't know I didn't mean it as an
excuse I meant it as like something that
maybe could help him see outside what he
thinks is true about Jews yeah and maybe
we're the gals to do it I totally agree
like the invitation is us giving him a
guided tour of yadashem patreon
stop not us monetizing the Holocaust
stuff yeah no okay we'll do we'll do it
just on our YouTube channel for free
um no and by the way and if we monetized
it they'd be like those shoes totally
um and I just I want anyone let's
if you know someone or you yourself
think that Jews control the media
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to Google Claudia ashrae look at the
pictures that show up look at the
articles that show up look about the the
lies that show up about me if I
controlled the media because I'm Jewish
um it would look so different like I
would literally have all the pictures
from my pj place thing up there like I
would have cute new photos of me and
like selfies our new Rebrand a Rebrand
yeah I just I can't stress enough like
that's literally the solid proof that
you need that Jews don't control their
media because my Wikipedia my Google
would look so different yeah
yep also he tweeted like right after he
was out to go Defcon 3. he had said like
who do you think started cancel culture
not my [ __ ] not me don't put that [ __ ]
on me don't put that [ __ ] on me
today's episode is brought to you by
honey thank you honey for sponsoring
today's episode the easy way to save
When shopping on your iPhone or computer
so we've talked about honey a lot and I
think a really new exciting development
in Honey's ethos is that they now have
their browser extension available for
iPhones so of course you shop online on
your computer if you're on the train
you're on a plane you're always on your
phone you can now have those amazing
savings with honey from your iPhone so
thanks to Honey manually searching for a
coupon code is a thing of the past honey
is the free shopping tool that scours
the internet for promo codes and it
applies the best one it finds to your
cart so here's how it works imagine
you're shopping online at one of your
favorite stores personally I've saved on
makeup on clothing on food on
electronics so many of the websites that
I shop at very frequently use honey if
not all of them so when you're shopping
at your favorite site check out the
honey button will appear and all you
have to do is Click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey will search for
coupons that it can find
and if they find a working coupon you
will just watch your price drop so I'm
never not surprised at Honey like I'll
be shopping for like I was just shopping
for our Halloween costume on like an
obscure website honey it's not just like
the big ones they've got really so many
retailers on there that they work with
and it's just a fabulous easy way to
save money and it's free when you use
our link so if you don't already have
honey you are missing out by getting it
you're doing yourself a solid we'd never
recommend something that we don't use so
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
toast that's
j-o-i-n-honey
h-o-n-e-y.com slash toast because honey
doesn't just work on desktop it also
works on your iPhone just activated on
Safari on your phone and save on the go
so get honey for free at joinhoney.com
toast great thank you mclartia you're
welcome for all the links and all the
codes that'll save
especially that should be Honey's jingle
100
first story some TV shake-up news Blake
Shelton will depart The Voice after next
season and Niall Horan and Chance the
Rapper joined Kelly Clarkson as judges
so after more than a decade ago on a
decade on The Voice Blake Shelton is
preparing to say goodbye NBC has
announced that the next season of the
singing competition will be Shelton's
last they also announced yesterday in a
series of cryptic Instagram posts that
Claudia completely felt for fell for I
thought it was a collab oh my God she
was like some big mad meanwhile she did
extra promo for The Voice yesterday I
literally thought Kelly Clarkson was
doing a song with Chance the Rapper and
I was like oh my God this is going to be
the song of the season so chance Kelly
Niall Horan and Blake Shelton all posted
a peace sign to their Instagram a peace
sign emoji which is also a V for voice
very cool oh I missed that yes also very
Churchill of them V for victory and for
vagina and for you know Churchill used
to walk around like this yes I know all
he was missing
duck face and turning it to the side
um and so like Kelly tag chance chance
tag Blake Blake tag Nile all around the
it was a cute way to promote the new
judge yes so twofold news is that Chance
the Rapper Niall Horan are joining the
voices judges and then next season will
be Blake Shelton's last and he is the
last OG
judge so let's talk about the voice
because currently I was watching me and
Ben like randomly watched it a couple
weeks ago and I was I always think like
if I was auditioning like whose team
would I go on if they all turned for me
and I honestly was thinking like I would
not choose one single person that they
have right now right now it's Blake
Shelton and Gwen Stefani there
Camila Cabello and John Legend So if I
had to I'd probably pick Camila Cabello
because like maybe I'd get to meet
Taylor Swift I think but at that point
you go with the person who you think
maybe you could like strike up a
friendship with Camila Cabello yeah so I
was thinking how like and even though
all four of those people like are stars
it's just kind of like a lackluster
lineup especially when we are coming off
of Ariana Grande season which people
loved so I was really surprised when
like I just realized how it's kind of
like a low
Star Quality even though they're all
stars I just can't explain like they're
not there's no mega star no they're so I
think the shake-up is really good I mean
Chance the Rapper is huge Niall Horan is
going to be amazing he's got a great
personality too like you can't just be
talented like you have to also be funny
and personable and he has a huge
audience which I'm sure they're
interested in and Kelly's back which is
but who's the fourth
they need a country person to replace
Blake let's theorize
I think it'll do a country female
I mean if they got Morgan Wallen that
would be crazy because Morgan Wallen
started on the voice that would be crazy
but he's at the peak of his career and
unless you're Ariana Grande like you
really don't do those types of shows
when you're at your Peak no and I'm sure
they paid her more money than she could
ever turn down I don't think they would
offer him the same so like the country
stars that are having a moment right now
Luke Combs Morgan wall and Kelsey
ballerini maren Morris like they're not
gonna do it no but let me ask you
something right now the voice is it two
men and two women
yes I think they'll probably stick with
that so I think it would be a female
country star I would I mean Carrie
Underwood it would be crazy if Miranda
Lambert did it because like her and
Blake Shelton are ex-wife and husband
and like that would just be awkward I
don't think she would do it because I
think she does not like this the
storyline of her and Blake Shelton's
marriage but someone like that yeah
Carrie Underwood it would be crazy if
Carrie Underwood and Kelly Clarkson were
both judges on The Voice because they
both started on American Idol but Carrie
Underwood is a great guess yeah
I think I'll be a country female I also
think it's weird they're announcing the
judges for next season when this season
just started oh is that what it is
they're like I think they're just
wrapping up the blind auditions oh
that's weird yeah
that's really weird I do think it's
Blake's time like the show was amazing
for him I feel like it officially put
him in like retirement like he still
releases new music and stuff but he's
more like a celebrity and personality
now than he is like a country singer I
feel like the 10 years that he's been on
all these other male country artists
kind of like surpassed him yeah but I
also think it helped him distinguish
himself from the pool of male country
artists that if you're not really in
country you just kind of associate with
each other
so true I also think he made so much
money like I think he can truly just
retire and he met his lady love and
that's priceless 100 percent
they really are like
a real they're like a little annoying on
the show they're a movie that feels like
a movie they're a little annoying on the
show
I don't watch so not my problem yeah who
would you choose right out of
the current judges Camilla John Legend
Blake Shelton and Gwen
Blake Shelton
yeah
I also have the best friends yeah like
yeah I'm a winner yeah even though the
people from The Voice who have like made
it big are not the winners
right but
but they are country usually also
Blake's even if they don't win they go
far like RaeLynn never forget Wait no
that's what I'm saying like most of the
people who have come from the Voice who
made it big and didn't win are country
yeah because of like yeah
cool cool beans our next story some sad
news Murder She Wrote actress Angela
Lansbury has died at the age of 96.
she's also as we would know her from
Beauty and the Beast the original Mrs
Potts I didn't know that yes so she
passed away the children of Dame Angela
Lansbury put out a statement said they
are sad
then she was Dame is a title that you're
given right by the queen right right wow
they said they were sad to announce that
their mother died peacefully in her
sleep at her home in La at 1 30 a.m on
Tuesday just five days shy of her 97th
birthday is this your way of subtly
doing a royal story no because there's a
part two to this story that uh it's a
old story of Angela Lansbury who's
that's recirculating that's so
fascinating that I also wanted to talk
about so she in an interview in 2014
told the story of how when she was like
big in Hollywood her kids and I think
her daughter joined like a bad she
started hanging out with like a bad guy
who's like making her steal and like on
drugs and like doing bad things
no and it would be earlier than that so
she like picked up her whole family and
moved them to Ireland
wow the bad guy Charles Manson oh oh my
God not her maternal Instinct being on
point yeah
wait that's so crazy so crazy like she
uh the interview was originally with
mail online but the independent
resurfaced it and it gives the details
of like what her daughter was doing with
Charles Manson and she just had to like
had to get a bad feeling yeah wow I mean
that it takes an extremely strong person
to move your entire family to another
country especially when you're having
like
amazing success and we love a queen who
doesn't get you know swooped up by the
Hollywood hoopla yeah so I find that
story to be so fascinating that is
really interesting I'm sure her kids are
enormously grateful yeah wow that's
crazy I didn't know she was a Dane
either and of course maybe there's Mrs
pops
so who are the current Dames we've got
Maggie Smith okay Judy Dench Seamus
Dames Helen Mirren yeah
14 celebrities made a knight or a queen
so well a night yeah I think it's Elton
John Paul McCartney is a sir okay Judy
Dench
professed the woman oh Maggie Smith
Professor McGonagall well uh
how would your downtus Paul McCartney is
knighted Elton John is knighted Julie
Andrews and Elizabeth Taylor
by the way dumb question do you have to
be British
Miss Congeniality he does deserve oh I
[ __ ] love that guy Helen Mirren
Mick Jagger
but the queen refused to give Mick
Jagger his Knighthood so Prince Charles
gave it to him instead
maybe the queen was nervous she would be
swept away about by his moves with his
moves like Jagger no she said because or
this article reportedly from a website
I've never heard
um said it was because of his
anti-establishment views
not the queen getting political and Bill
Gates is an honorary Knight oh well sure
Angelina Jolie received honorary
damehood but we don't call her Dame
Angelina
yeah no okay I don't care anymore
Anna Wintour is a Dame I don't care
anymore like this this is seeming false
so
um I'm wishing Angela Angela Lansbury's
family well
rip Angela
don't
are you ready for our next story I don't
give a rip yeah Khloe Kardashian had
tumor removed from her face Khloe
Kardashian had a tumor removed nearly 20
years after finding a cancerous mole on
her back the reality is 20 years 20
years ago she had a mole removed on her
back that was cancerous oh wow I think
we knew that I think she shared that
before uh she wrote via Instagram
stories yesterday that she has seen
numerous stories going around about the
ever-evolving bandage on her face over
the past years
she set the record straight explaining
that she had a small bump on her cheek
biopsied after it refused to budge for
seven months after the growth was
examined by two doctors she was advised
to have an immediate operation to remove
the tumor she said I'm grateful to share
that Dr Fisher was able to get
everything and her margins appear clear
now
we love a transparent Queen so happy
that everything is okay and
I guess me and Chloe have much in common
because we both get molds removed yeah
also this is just a great reminder for
everyone
and also it is Breast Cancer Awareness
Month so get your mammogram season yeah
and totally
I'm grateful to Chloe for reminding us
to make that reminder totally those full
body checks at the dermatologist
especially if you have a male
dermatologist are some of the worst
moments of your life but you know what
else is the worst moment cancer so go
get checked go get checked
thanks for the reminder especially if
you're like a moly girly like there are
two types of people in this world Molly
girls and non-molly girls but also
freckly like
um
if you have a lot of freckles
okay but that's not part of what I'm
saying no but in terms of getting
checked but I'm just saying like there's
two types of girlies like Molly girls
and non-mally girls like either you're a
girl with moles or you're a girl without
moles
girl with them all in the words of
Danielle's tab there is no in between
with me you know you're either a mole or
not mole
I don't know if there's anyone who has
zero moles actually Dana will know I'll
ask her yeah and if there is I would
like to interview that person like to
ask them probably like all about their
Blissful upbringing their mole free life
their mole free life their
self-conscious free life I'm sure
they're the most confident person I'd
like to talk to them you'd be shocked to
hear what other issues plague them no
it's not because if everyone is dealt a
hand of cards no because no if you're
dealt a hand without moles you're
special
you're special okay well we will
identify if there is uh zero mole
Personnel mole woman
um are you ready for our next story only
if it's the next story that's sponsored
by Jackie's favorite sponsor hands down
is it the one that I can't stop singing
about
no no no it's the one it's the one that
you can't stop referencing about
language
babble if you're like us and there's a
foreign language that you regret not
learning in school it is never too late
to start with Babel Babel is a language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions thanks to their
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons you can finally cross
learning that new language off your list
so if you want us to learn a new
language for whatever reason to expand
your horizons are you taking a trip it's
actually really important to like know
the basics of the language of the
country that you're traveling to just
like for safety reasons whatever your
reasoning is you really should check out
Babel because it's not like other
language learning companies you only
need 10 minutes with Babel to complete a
lesson so you can start having real life
conversations in the new language in as
little as three weeks other language
learning apps use AI for their lesson
plans but Baba lessons were created by
over 150 language experts and they're
voiced by real native speakers not
computers their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
and you can choose from 14 different
languages with Babel Spanish French
Italian and German
um when I went to Italy I did Babel for
a few weeks before and it was like
enormously helpful just to like know how
to say like I'm lost where's the
bathroom thank you please like it's
really a great thing to do if you love
to travel and if you don't love to
travel it's a great thing to do just
expand your mind you know read books
learn new languages such a good hobby
and like something to check off your
list also Claudia is taking a trip later
I'm not gonna like spoil it or anything
and she's oh yeah I'm already on her
Babble grind just learning about a few
pointer words
um there are so many ways to learn with
Babel in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts Games videos stories
even live classes and it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee so start
your new language learning Journey today
with Babel right now you can get up to
55 off your subscription when you go to
babel.com
TMT that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com TMT for up to 55 off
your subscription Babble language for
life
next story some sweet new couple news
Emma eligible Bachelorette Emma Roberts
is dating actor Cody John after her
split with Garrett hubland Emma Roberts
has been reportedly dating actor Cody
John for a few months the actress and
John met through mutual friends
according to e-news who the hell is Cody
John I don't know I Googled him I don't
know what he like the things that he's
been in I haven't seen but he posted a
picture of them smooching on his
Instagram and you have other posts on
his Instagram of them like hanging out
in August
and now someone is speaking to e-news
confirming it saying Emma loves Cody's
personality he's really funny and that
they have been having a great time
together
I think that's good because as much as I
loved the fact that she was dating
Garrett Hedlund for so long they had a
baby together I do think their
relationship was extremely tumultuous
um and chaotic and not good so while I
have a deep and special place in my
heart for Garrett hudlund thanks to
Georgia Rule and Country Strong two of
the greatest movies of all time who's
common denominator is Garrett Hedlund I
I think it's for the best I do
but he drunk drove oh
my God I forgot I forgot I forgot [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is where my morals like
I'm I'm inclined to throw them out the
way no you have it's more important when
your morals get tough and when your
convictions get tough you have to stand
your ground no when times get tough my
morals get going like you don't need to
be scrupled
[ __ ]
ah
I
I can't
I'm sorry to remind you but like you
love it if we were a story about Sam
Hunt we'd be talking about it yeah of
course because I don't even like Sam
Hunt so like that's easy to be scrupled
of course
oh my God no like I love Garrett
Headland I'm sorry I still do
I do but you can seriously condemn drunk
driving 100 every known in your body
it's bad
it's bad yeah really bad
thanks for ruining my day
anyways Emma Roberts is having a good
day because she has a new man's and
she's so eligible she's so eligible and
if she wasn't in a new relationship I
would be putting her on the list
to set her up yeah and
um I'm glad that she's
finding romance me too and I'm sure it's
serious if they've gone public and she
has uh her baby now you know like I
don't think she's yes like new Mamas are
as flippant with like relationships when
obviously there's someone else to
consider and and the source talks about
that in this article too 100 cautious
bringing her son around new people yeah
100 100 are you ready for our fifth and
final story I am a little light Fair
Bridal news Nikki Bella [ __ ] I sent you
a story today I'm oh my God sorry no
It's Time by the [ __ ] time oh my God
I start being heard around can I explain
I literally checked my phone five
minutes ago because I remember you said
I I had a DM from you saying let's talk
about this today so I just checked my
phone to see what it was I was going to
slot it in and may am I allowed a slip
of the mind but why do your slips only
come when I request stories
that's not true Gwyneth Paltrow on Shark
Tank you totally forgot oh my God
uh you said these days all the time and
I always incorporate them but I know I
don't get credit for that Max Max Max
once a month
I would say
four stories a week you send me
oh
so fun for you like being delusional I'm
not even I was gonna go to your story
like can't you just
forgive and move on
I want to forgive you and I want to
forget you well that's going to be
really hard because we do the show
together every day it is hard
and this didn't have to turn into this
because I was agreeing with you I had
already folded over my iPad
okay let's talk about you won't hear
about how Nikki Bella chose her wedding
dress 30 minutes before her wedding
oh that's interesting we'll talk about
it tomorrow
anyways the thing that Claudia did send
me was Rachel bilson's podcast brought
ideas she had on her podcast hold on I
don't want the audio to start playing
she had on Alexis nyers and Gabby from
The Bling Ring and they are talking
about the robbery and Rachel is
forgiving them and moving on so if
Rachel can forgive them I can forgive
you for forgetting my story I wish
shocked I was shocked when I heard this
clip first of all the fact that like
they're acknowledging like Rachel Bilson
is acknowledging Alexis nairs was just
crazy and that they were in the same
room podcasting but also Rachel was
extremely forgiving she was like trying
to help Alexis deal with the fact that
like Alexis lives with this regret and
this guilt
um and of all the people who got robbed
like Rachel got robbed really badly and
Rachel
um lost a family hair Loom her mother's
engagement ring like it was so much more
than just like diamonds and cash like it
was really sentimental stuff and Rachel
was like I've moved on from it so long
ago you need to move on from it you need
to forgive yourself you can't keep
walking around with this it could never
be me
it could never be me either but you do
hear these stories like of forgiveness
of forgiveness even in like my drug and
alcohol abuse course they had these like
two stories of two people who drunk
drove kill people when you keep talking
about your drug and alcohol of course it
sounds like you were like sentenced to
right that I've been like rehabilitated
no in order to get your permit in
Florida you need to take a four hour
drug and alcohol abuse Court class that
um shows you the dangers of drinking and
driving I just feel like every time you
bring up your drug and alcohol course
like you need to mention right okay so
in the course that I had to take because
I just want to get my permit like
nothing in the ferry has happened
um there were these two cases of people
who drunk drove killed other people like
they weren't injured but now they're
spending their lives in prison and the
family members of the people who they
killed it's been like 10 15 years have
forgiven them and now it's like you have
to forgive yourself you hear about that
a lot like I think it's probably harder
to forgive yourself than of course to
forgive the person who wronged you yeah
um I just thought it was very big of
Rachel Bilson and I love Rachel Bilson
please don't tell me she drove and drank
too not that I'm aware of
um so this just made me love her even
more it's like such a mature thing to do
she didn't even have to acknowledge
Alexis like I think but the conversation
they had was like the way that the media
glamorized this whole thing and how the
movie continued to right
um I did finish The Bling Ring
documentary
and there was like a Twist at the end
because like everyone on there was just
like being delusional um and talking
about like social media like they had
that guy Nick and like Perez Hilton and
then they had someone come in at the end
and be like these people like who you're
hearing from like they are the problem
like they're exactly what's wrong and
how things like The Bling Ring happen
like this obsession with celebrity and
being famous and it was like they kind
of flipped the whole conversation on its
head I kind of loved it oh that's it
also victim blaming Paris Hilton how so
like she perpet she's like the the face
of this culture being obsessed with Fame
and celebrities so like it's only you
know a matter of time before she got
robbed like what
sock
sock yeah they were like kind of victim
blaming Paris I did not like that that's
weird
um
and I agree just and Rachel talked about
like the glamorization I only saw the
one clip that you sent me I also feel
like this is like the fact that she's
sitting down with Alexis and I are is
like it's just the power of podcasting
like a hundred I don't think they would
be getting together if like Alexis has a
podcast Rachel's a podcaster we're both
in the news like let's podcast
a lot of ways podcasting is probably
facilitating
important conversations that that might
not be had otherwise I mean look at us
important conversations daily minutely
on the rag yeah no I agree this is a
true Testament to the power of
podcasting I couldn't have said it
better myself
um and this I was just shocked like when
I saw this clip going around I'm like
wait there's no way that's Alexis nyers
like well when I first saw the clip I
they don't have video so it's just like
pictures of races talking and I was like
oh Rachel's talking about it on her show
and then I read the caption and it said
like she's talking about it with Alexis
and Gabby I was like [ __ ] no this is so
crazy I'm surprised more people aren't
talking about it yeah also the
glamorization of past crimes
and
this brings me back to the Jeffrey
Dahmer thing that we talked about people
that didn't like what we said about it
but the more I've uh seen and heard
about Jeffrey Dahmer still haven't
watched it but my husband was watching
it so I saw like some stuff and I've
been reading more like media seven from
the victims families like the more sh
certain I am like why is this the
content that we're creating like that so
let me just say people didn't like what
we said and they were 100 right because
we literally didn't know what we were
talking about like we didn't know about
like his specific crimes but right like
he targeted gay men and exclusively yes
and but what we were our larger point
was like why are we watching shows about
people like this even if they're not
glamorizing it necessarily the fact that
it's a Hollywood production Jeffrey
Dahmer's played by Evan Peters like it's
glamorous the fact I stand by what we
said is number one in the country and so
everyone is just sitting at home
watching these
horrendous crimes heinous crimes
unimaginable crimes is so Twisted to me
I completely agree I stand by what we
said completely I stand by like the more
I hear about it the and I saw a story
from like one of the victims families
there was an episode that focused on one
victim in particular and I guess like
his trial and everything and so they're
using the victim's name and his family's
name and they're like the victim's
family is like how are they allowed to
do this how are they allowed to like
consent talk about us and portray us
it's I I find it so wrong and it me too
it makes me feel like in
to 15 years 20 years like they're going
to be making
movies or shows about like the worst
crimes committed today like no by the
way the turnaround time is fast as [ __ ]
it's fast as ever but I do think like
getting away from it you become
desensitized yes and I think that back
in the 70s like serial killers were
I don't want to say trendy but that was
what the crazy people were doing yeah
I think it's morphed
to today where that's not as much what's
happening but we see like mass shootings
right it's happening now and so like
totally think about the fact that in
what 10 years are we gonna have an
origin story about the Uvaldi school
shooter no by the way we are
um I totally agree I think this true
crime like Niche has taken a wild turn I
don't think it's like funny anymore I
don't think it's respectful and I think
like nobody ever thinks about how like
the fam like the living family members
of these victims who are re-traumatized
every time there's a new documentary or
a new TV show is so [ __ ] up and I
don't watch [ __ ] like that I I won't
watch [ __ ] like that and I genuinely
like don't understand yeah
so stand by what we said
I do apologize that we didn't know the
extent of his crimes and and yeah but
that's like what we were talking about
with Jessica Knoll
she agreed yes exactly
so those were the past five don't go
anywhere because it's dear toaster's
time we will uh every Wednesday if you
want to write into deertoesters
gmail.com we do our best to help our
toasters in need whether it's work
related relationship related family
related personal hygiene related we're
going to do our very best we're gonna do
our damnedest to help you girl these out
and it's brought to you by Bruce the
electric toothbrush that will change the
way you think about brushing your teeth
with powerful Sonic technology and Ultra
Gentle bristles the Bruce redefines what
it means to have super clean teeth
so the brush is everything of the sort
it is the official toothbrush of the
morning toast I'm sure you all have it
if you don't like what are you waiting
for it's time to switch to an electric
toothbrush first of all because it's so
much better for your teeth it's so much
better for the environment and a lot of
them can be really expensive I think the
brush is super affordable compared to
others on the market and it has
everything that you need the magnetic
charging stand the Sleek travel case a
two minute timer with a quad Pacer so
you're getting all of your teeth for all
of the time
um it has different modes so you can use
the gentle mode if you have sensitive
gums you can use the white mode to help
remove tough surface stains and they
also have the tongue mode to keep that
stanky Stanky Breath at Bay
he can keep his tongue
I agree
I agree and you'll want to if you're
using Bruce
I agree I agree get 20 off when you pick
up your brush brush kit and plan when
you go to brush.com toast Bruce is
spelled
b-r-u-u-s-h that's bruce.com and 20 off
when you go to brush.com toast when you
get the kit it includes the electric
toothbrush three brush heads that you
should change out every couple of months
so you keep that breath nice and tight
at the magnetic charging station and the
Sleek travel case at brush.com toast oh
raw a ready
um
again if you want to write in it's
deertoesters gmail.com try and keep it
brief just like with the need to know
information we can't be reading a whole
novel here um as much as we would love
to if we see yours is that like a little
bit too long like we are going to skip
it I'm sorry
all right hey girlies love the Rebrand
thank you obviously okay so we know this
is a woman of taste or man
I'll make it short and sweet my husband
is seriously the best except when it
comes to the one thing that completely
grosses me out he rarely washes his
hands after using the bathroom at first
he tried to tell me that it was only
when he went number one and that guys
don't need to do that if
they actually need to do it more but
okay I've recently noticed him not
washing his hands after he goes poop too
whenever I hear a flush and it is not
followed by the sound of running water I
get disgusted and usually question did
you wash your hands sometimes he grunts
annoyed and goes back into the bathroom
to do it other times he yells at me to
just stop is this a guy thing we have
two little boys who are starting to pick
everything up and I don't want them to
eventually think that this is normal
behavior also like don't touch me or my
babies with your German fested hands
help I'm starting to feel like a Naggy
wench the thing about being a Naggy
[ __ ] wife which I am is you have to
pick your battles so it's important to
take inventory and be like is this
battle worth picking this battle I do
believe is worth picking especially when
it comes to number two yeah I don't know
what is Tech is like considered normal
when it comes to washing your hands
after going to the bathroom like I wash
my hands every time I go like wouldn't
even occur to me not to whether I'm
going number one or two three four five
six seven eight nine ten like I wash my
hands every single time that's why if I
ever have spray tan or use self tanner
my hands are always white like I wash
them after everything I know I could say
I wash my hands when I'm out in public
100 of the time in the comfort of my own
home I'm gonna go with like an 83 okay I
know that there are people who don't
wash their hands after they pee but
always do it after number two so if he's
not washing his hands and I do think men
need to do it more after number one than
women because they're touching the
orifice like we're using toilet paper I
do think sometimes if you're peeing and
you wipe like you could literally get up
off the toilet with no bacteria on your
hands like if if done correctly if done
correctly but just in case for that
margin of error wash your hands
um
so he should be washing his hands like
as a human being but also like as a
father now you really don't want your
kids to think that that's even an option
because of course they won't wash their
hands who wants to wash their hands and
kids like just have so many germs that
they carry that they transmit to one
another like you want to get your kids
in the business of washing their hands
and for that reason he needs to make a
bigger effort so I think a general rule
of thumb when you're starting to feel
like a Naggy [ __ ] wife which is the
worst [ __ ] feeling is to assess how
important this particular thing is and I
do think that this is I mean have we
learned nothing from the pandemic like
you gotta you gotta be clean right but
it's like
it's different than pandemic because
it's just like your fecal matter and
stuff no but still it's just like
General hygiene yeah like we know the
importance of washing your hands now you
know what I mean yes
yes I think that you should fight for
this just because it's a good example to
set and even if your kids only absorb
like 50 of what you're trying to tell
them to do you need to start at 100 but
you also want your kids to listen to you
and your kids are going to do as you do
not as you say Practice What You Preach
you have to practice what you preach
because then you're just a hypocrite but
one thing about me is like when
you know God willing I become a parent
like I will be a hypocrite it's salads
for everyone McDonald's for me
yes but also like I do think sometimes
not like about washing your hands but
sometimes like there's different roles
for children than there are for adults
like we are not the same right right
like I can wear makeup you can't of
course right right but still like I just
that I think people keep asking me when
I'm gonna write my next book and by
people I mean like three people
um and I do think I probably will wait
to write another book till I have a
child and it's going to be called like
the hypocritical mom because I'm it's
too as I say not as I do I think a lot
of moms follow that because it's too
late for me you know but it's not too
late for you yeah no but it's like I can
curse you can of course I can yeah
that's gonna be a problem for me I'm
just gonna I'm gonna have those kids I'm
okay with it there's worse things
there's worse things like they're not
doing crack so no a [ __ ] here and there
I'm okay with it all right next up hey
Jackson Club
love you guys and I love the toastery
brand already I need your advice the
other night two of my friends got too
drunk on a night out and started [ __ ]
talking my boyfriend and my relationship
basically they were saying he treats me
badly and it couldn't be further from
the truth it is the best and healthiest
relationship I've ever been in and all
my other friends agree with that when I
asked one of my girl one of the girls
after I found out she took full
responsibility and apologized oh you
weren't there no I feel completely
betrayed by this and I don't want to
lose my friend but it made me feel
insecure and Confused any advice on what
I should do
sounds like you got a couple gels
winches on your hands and you know the
only way to handle a jealous wedge
hmm
I don't know I was gonna flip to you oh
I
I think that you there's could be like
room for forgiveness here as we've
stated so many times about the
housewives like you could say something
mean when you're drunk that you don't
really mean and if your friend like took
full responsibility apologized I think
you guys need to like explore it further
and be like well why did you say that
stuff like do you really mean it if you
think he's a bad boyfriend like like let
her explain speak on it and then you can
explain like why he's not and why you're
so happy I think you should work through
it
but I honestly think like It's upsetting
but they also if they're both single
like they might be jealous jealous and
you can know that in the back of your
mind and like not that it's an excuse
but
now you know how it happened no but also
I do feel like and they don't even have
to be single they could be in bad
relationships themselves and be with
female friendships I just feel like
there's a certain level of [ __ ] talking
that's expected like I don't know like
it's just part of The Human Experience
like we're three best friends and two of
us are going out like we're gonna talk
about the third one like is that crazy
like I just think we all need to like
lower our expectations a little bit like
friends talk about friends like it's
it's just part of The Human Experience
yeah that is true
I wouldn't want to lose a friend over it
and so right if I were the one on the
receiving end I thought I was someone
who like I found out they were talking
about me uh depending on which friend it
is and what they said like I would try
and work through it if it was the
opposite if someone caught me talking
crap
I would want the chance to explain
myself or just completely apologize if
what I said was something I truly didn't
mean right right
um give it a chance I don't think like
in this present moment this is a reason
enough to like write people off
completely because people are people and
they talk like it's just it's who we are
I agree with that we need to be like a
little bit more forgiving on the [ __ ]
talking front I agree all right third
and final hey girlies here's the deal
long time toaster OG brother thank you
for the show I can't tell you how many
times listening in has pulled me out of
a funk or a cast or Cast Away my bad
mood oh my that's so nice
so my husband total pay job moved four
hours from home to be with me and I
gained my dream job as a NICU nurse
is it a Nico nurse and I said
yeah I think I say niku and I'm wrong
okay
um we have been living here for over two
years now at times we miss some of our
friends and family but we go up to our
hometown quite a bit and people always
make time to come see us except my
mother-in-law the excuses range from
unrealistic weather forecasts to just
she's too busy this weekend but she
always makes sure to ask us when we will
be visiting next or even asking us when
we are moving back my husband has made
it very clear to her that this is our
new life and that she needs to accept it
but I can see that it bothers him that
she still hasn't made an effort to come
visit us there's a part of me that wants
to confront her and tell her she needs
to make a plan to come down to be there
for her son but there's another part of
me that wants to have a full-blown
standoff with her to see how far she'll
take this my husband and I are trying
for a baby and it makes me question if
she'll even make the effort when we get
pregnant and or have a baby what would
you guys do a conflicted daughter-in-law
um I'm like I'm a stubborn wench like I
am tempted to go stand off like fine
don't see your grandbaby that's on you
but she is an older woman yeah no I
don't know that this would bother me so
much because some girls would crave this
by the way yeah it depends on your
situation and not because like I would
be glad that she's not coming but like
everybody is going through their own
stuff like she's an older woman like you
don't know why she doesn't want to come
down but also like maybe she just wants
you to come to her and like even if that
means she sees you less like it's maybe
she can't make the trip for one reason
or another right like she's probably
just expecting that anytime you guys see
each other it'll be you coming to her
and as you know when you have respect
for your parents and you're the younger
party you do have to kind of respect
that so I don't think it's so crazy
um
but it I imagine being a wife and seeing
your husband like sad about something
his mom is doing like you feel helpless
and like you want to be helpful right
but I would just want to understand why
she's not coming like
four hours like treacherousness I assume
it's in the car
yeah I think so
I would like maybe you could get maybe
it's like she doesn't want to drive
maybe you could get like a driver for
her whatever drive down there yourself
yeah like find out what it is that
that's like that block for her I don't
think it's just her like not wanting to
see you guys yeah there's probably a
reason like maybe she's too old to do
the trip alone maybe she can't sit in a
car for that long figure it out yeah
halfway I would
I would advise to be like a little
open-minded about it and not just assume
the worst yes I agree that's fair that
she's being just one Chief or Wednesday
it's so hard to tell though when
someone's being a wench and when they're
not yeah especially when you like me
assume the worst in other people
you know I don't think that you do
though
I think that I do actually like I'm I'm
self-aware enough to know like I'm
always seeing the worst in people but I
think you like take pause you know only
when I ask you and you're like pause
well you pause enough to ask me
yeah that's fair that's fair maybe am I
like an amazing person yes
so that was your toasters again if you
want to write in it's deertoesters
gmail.com thank you to everyone who
wrote in for today's episode tomorrow's
episode I'm Gonna Be Live from Nashville
so I'm excited to see you guys then and
see you guys at my show tomorrow night
tickets available at upyourass.com
because you're too late [ __ ] you're too
[ __ ] late [ __ ]
at your ass.com okay let me write that
down yeah just pencil it in thank you
guys so much for listening to the toast
the Millennium Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know everybody through Friday on
YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so at Spotify
iTunes Stitcher public radio
iheartradiocastbox all the places
whoever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
oh the toast I'll leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
incredib hump day don't forget to hump
someone you love and we'll see you
tomorrow bye